more gears of war details for any
budding cog soldier I'm Dave and welcome
to your two-player game spot news update
even more gears of war for details have
emerged thanks to game informer's cover
story on the upcoming Xbox one game we
have already learned about the game's
main characters including Marcus Fenix
his son and now that the full April
issue is available more gameplay and
story details have come to light one
notable piece of information is that
gears of war 4 will offer two player
co-op which is scaled back from 4 player
support in Gears of War 3 this being the
case for both local play and online
player 1 is always JD phoenix whilst
player 2 can choose between K&L while
the three main characters remain
together for most of the game at times
they might get split up and the story
has subtle differences depending on
whether player 2 is Kate or del this
according to game informer as the story
details it's now been confirmed that
gears of wars full story which takes
place on Sarah 25 years that the gears
of war 3 will unfold over a period of
just 24 hours the game informer story
also reveals that whilst the emotion
weapon set off at the end of gears of
war 3 successfully killed all the
locusts it's also knocked out all fossil
fuels there are only a few hundred
thousand people left on Sarah and gears
of war 4 and cog forces round everyone
up and put them in walled in structures
not everyone is happy and a splinter
group The Outsiders form outside the
walls there's this notion that the COG
is like an overprotective parent trying
to preserve life and ensure people
safety the outsiders are a group of
people who are purposely stepping
outside the COG and breaking free
because they think life isn't worth
living unless it's live free as we were
conceptualizing the outsiders we
initially started with the hippie
movement but then we realize we wanted
them to have an edge and we started
thinking of them like this 1970s
motorcycle gang so are you excited about
the next muscular iteration of franchise
let us know in the comments section
below or find me on Twitter at irregular
Dave and for your gears of war news stay
tuned to gamespot com